T
THE SPECIAL MASTER CAN REVIEW AS
IT PERTAINS TO THE 100
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
JAKE?
>> JESSICA, THANK YOU.
>>> FORM PRESIDENT TRUMP ADDRESS
ED A RALLY THIS WEEKEND.
THERE WERE MANY BIZARRE MOMENTS,
INCLUDING WHAT APPEARS TO BE
ECHOES OF THE QANON CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
PROPAGANDA THAT TRUMP HAS SHARED
IN RECENT WEEKS.
SARA SIDNER IS LIVE WITH MORE ON
THIS.
SARA, CAN YOU POINT TO THE
THINGS THAT TRUMP SAID OR DID
THAT ARE LINKED TO THE QANON
CONSPIRACY?
>> Reporter: YEAH, JAKE, THIS
WEEKEND, TRUMP MADE A VERY
OMINOUS SPEECH ABOUT THE DECLINE
OF AMERICA AND WHILE DOING SO,
MUSIC BEGAN PLAYING AND THE
MUSIC SOUNDED EXACTLY LIKE A
SONG CALLED "WHERE WE GO ONE, WE
GO ALL."
A SLOGAN USED OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN BY QANON.
FOR SOME IN THE QANON WORLD,
THIS WAS ANOTHER SYMBOL, A WINK
AND A NOD TO THEM, THAT DONALD
TRUMP IS A BELIEVER IN THEIR
CONSPIRACIES.
BUT THAT PALES IN COMPARISON TO
SOMETHING THAT TRUMP DID THAT
INDICATED A SINNER GUY WITH
QANON.
THE IMAGE, TRUMP WEARING A QANON
PIN.
THIS IS A DIRECT REFERENCE TO
THE QANON CONSPIRACY THAT TRUMP
IS GOING TO RETURN TO POWER AND
GET RID OF HIS OPPONENTS BY
JAILING AND EXECUTING THEM.
SOME QANON BELIEVERS SAY THAT
TRUMP'S DEMOCRATIC OPPONENTS ARE
EVIL, THEY DRINK THE BLOOD OF
CHILDREN, AND THAT THEY ARE PART
OF A SHADOWY CABAL OF
PEDOPHILES.
PEOPLE ARE MOTIVATED ENOUGH TO
MAKE WAVES POLITICALLY AND IT
APPEARS THAT DONALD TRUMP WANTS
TO ENGAGE THEM.
THESE ARE NOT AT ALL THE FIRST
LINKS THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS MADE
WITH QANON, BUT THIS PAST
WEEKEND, HAVE BEEN THE MOST
OVERT.
WE WERE ABLE TO SPEAK TO A TRUMP
SPOKESPERSON WHO RESPONDED TO
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SONG THAT
WAS PLAYED, SAYING IT WAS NOT A
QANON SONG AT ALL, BUT A SONG
CALLED "MIRROR" AND THEN SAID
THIS, THAT THE FAKE NEWS IS A
PATHETIC ATTEMPT TO CREATE
CONTROVERSY AND DIVIDE AMERICA
AND IS BREWING UP ANOTHER DON
SPIR SI ABOUT A ROYALTY FREE
SONG FROM A POPULAR AUDIO
LIBRARY PLATFORM.
NOW, THE WAY THAT MEDIA MATTERS,
A GROUP WHICH TRACKS RIGHT WING
POLITICAL EXTREMISTS IN MEDIA,
SAYS TRUMP HAS POSTED OR
REPOSTED MORE THAN 100 MESSAGES
LINKED TO QANON SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR, JAKE.
>> IT'S UNSETTLES, BECAUSE
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN THIS
INSANE THEORY HAVE ACTUALLY
TAKEN THE LAW INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS AND KILLED INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT IS THE DANGER OF A
PRESIDENT ENGAGING AND WINKING
AND NODDING WITH THIS GROUP OF
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS, JUST
BEYOND THE SHEER MADNESS OF WHAT
THEY BELIEVE?
>> Reporter: YEAH, IT'S A REALLY
GOOD POINT THAT NEEDS TO BE
MADE.
IN JUNE, CNN REPORTED THAT THE
FBI WARNED LAWMAKERS THAT QANON
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS MAY CARRY
OUT MORE ACTS OF VIOLENCE AS
THEY MOVE FROM WHAT THEY CALL
THEMSELVES DIGITAL SOLDIERS TO
TAKING ACTION IN THE REAL WORLD.
VIOLENT ACTION.
THE REPORT SUGGESTS THE FAILURE
OF QANON PREDICTIONS TO
MATERIALIZE HAS NOT LED TO
FOLLOWERS LEAVING AND ABANDONING
THEIR CONSPIACY THEORIES.
AND